foreign [Music]
that's not a knife this is a knife oh crocodile
hey Greg talk to me I'm talking to you no talk
to me I am talking I'm trying to talk to you
okay well that's the name of the movie today
we're watching talk to me it's an a24 movie we
love 824 I know literally not one thing about
this you know more than me I I know I love what I
know and I'd like to share what I know okay talk
to me I'm not gonna talk about what the actual
movie is but the filmmakers behind it oh they
do have a YouTube channel called rackaracka it's
a great Channel like in their careers trajectory
to that of like Jordan peel when it comes to
Key and Peele to get out they do these like
crazy wild kinetic sketches that are very mature
that you can see how well they encapsulate their
knowledge of genre so well to see them go from
sketch comedy on YouTube to then doing a horror
film to a24 I'm like no that makes perfect sense
so I've been a big fan of their work for a very
very very long time this is the first movie I'm
watching where I'm proud of the filmmakers behind
it even though I haven't seen it wow damn you
said it's mature we're also very mature [Music]
to make a fart noise when I said machine yeah I
didn't if you think we're mature like this video
comment subscribe all that good stuff and if you
are a super sexy reject over on patreon and you
get our full-length Reaction watch long where
you sync up with your own copy as for the super
sexy rejects only for the very sexy sexy people
whoa how'd you do that the Rave glow stick move
nope yeah I didn't do it yeah I learned when I
was young my friend Yong Chong taught me it you go
slow am I doing it nope most people do this wait
wait what are you doing if you get when you know
like a Raves when you glow sticks very specific
movement Greg you're good at everything including
you and yeah including raving and you and John
covering several shows over there exclusively
with reaction highlights and watchalongs included
shall we stop talking to them and talk to me yeah
it's gonna talk to you the whole movie Roxy yeah
that would be that's usually what we do yeah we
get all the stars that's not how YouTube works
there's not Stars just back and forth will improve
you're talking about you do
this while do it slow sorry
oh I'm excited this is the most
excited I've seen you for a movie yeah
boy boy oh yes that's not nice [Music]
do you think the actor actually had to do
that yeah it looks like it they're in here
oh I'm gonna take you home okay bro I'm
upset you're gonna hurt a lot of people
Mommy this is a hell of an opening shot
they haven't cut yet is it a horror movie
yeah are you serious put your phones down
are they recording him bastards kill them
the brother just stabbed the other
brother yeah he's on drugs I have no idea
that's not a knife this is a knife this
is predicted the whole movie I predicted
the whole thing wow did you think those
were gonna be our two main characters
oh because I saw the poster okay because
I thought those were gonna be our two main
characters and I was just about to talk about how
much I liked them I feel like the dynamic tease
the psychological torture of what's to come for
our actual main character is she related to them
you talk to me as if I know the ins and
outs of the plot just made it a moment
your auntie wants to talk to you talk to me
Craig I'm begging talk to me I should call
her name in contacts wow and like stayed on that
blur shot it's a technical term I pulled the word
well you're getting the cold uh yeah I think
so I love her hair how was today for you
fine and her earrings and her costume
feel like we have a really good read of
character right now it's interesting they
kept the dad blurred this whole time again
that word blur keeps coming back in my brain
Focus defocus all right we'll just call Riley
she doesn't work up all right yeah and
have fun with you cancer so you feed us
foreign
[Music]
it's fun seeing an actual bonding
between like caretaker babysitter
I don't know I think they see something
oh no dear [__] oh it's kangaroo do we call
a vet Mr gonna help Riley I mean look at it
oh this is so sad can you at
least put it out of its misery
no put it out of its misery what are you
gonna do run over it I think so but then
she's gonna get arrested it's illegal to kill
kangaroos do you know that oh I don't want oh
no no I don't know that I'm just talking
out of my ass talk to me too out of my ass
I mean I know we can't leave it
like this another car woke up
Mia is crying interesting I wonder if
there's gonna be like consequences to
that choice of not putting it out of its misery
Greg they're driving on the wrong side of the
road yeah a little bunch of morons all you
dummies in Australia too gosh Greg oh Riley
[Music] thanks for picking up me all good come
on oh God what is the dynamic here hmm lovers and
sisters it's just how you like it perfect fantasy
come to life this happens when two men direct I'm
doing it again tonight not tonight it was mum's
two years I just want to forget about it I think
they're just friends why does she keeps saying mom
like it's their mom but they were like flirting
I'm a bad persons who can break a mirror
I wonder if we can get some body horror
stuff I think the main actress is very
natural she doesn't like overplay the the sadness
or anything like that it feels like a real person
who's grieving it's real natural performance
when you're sneaking out good to see Daniel
all right even if it was he's Ultra Christian he
doesn't do anything at all he's still [Laughter]
how could I say no to him whatever
the best friends and her mom took her in
that's the impression I'm getting you oh
I'm dating two apparently [__] me
like all of these three kids all of
them are really good I even think the
dialogue did you sound like actual people
talking I like the little boy it's just a
weird sentence to say it's okay you're
a woman he probably likes hearing that
that's a weird sentence to say I mean I
think he's very good music house just yeah
this reoccurring theme of Disconnect
dude why'd you have to bring him
what's wrong with her I think she's just a
Debbie Downer now she's flirting with your boy
they're friends Haley you
keep telling yourself that wow
I guess uh other fish yeah you always
go first that's my house would you
would you like this and why I don't know I think
they're doing a possession testing I'll do it
like from what they were seeing on The Tick
Tock videos yeah uh I guess it depends on this
like a Ouija board kind of thing I'm
not sure yet I like how they haven't
fully told us yet it's a nice tension to
it they really throw you into this hands up
this must have been a very strange script
on paper what happens after 90 seconds
don't want to stay
oh that's what happened with the guy who stabbed
his brother I guess so oh dude trust me It's
gotta be time I like how it's been so handheld
and now it's getting like still and focused
okay Maya
put your hand on it
now say icky talk to me
talk to me
whoa [Music]
come on man it's different every time you're gonna
say I let you in no I'm flipping out seriously
shut up no someone was sitting there I swear I
don't go prove it prove it that's why I say it
[Music] like just seeing kids take it in with such
Glee yeah the recording of like other people's
downfalls and Trauma is just so disturbing
getting like a high out of it it was crazy
[Applause] okay I let you in talk to me
weird say it
I let you in I let you in
someone coming got it whoa whoa there
you are cool Distortion of audio
[Laughter]
oh this is so uncomfortable I hate this Jesus
I like you what oh [__] not you there
are they keeping track of the time I don't
know okay it's 90 seconds it feels like
cool very Sam Raby he's behind you now
83 seconds Josh
hurry
help him run run run run run run run oh man
I think they're gonna get it
off I don't think so no I do but
it's like way past the 90 second Mark
now I don't know they said 83 seconds
seven seconds seven seconds you're in a bit over
amazing wow treating it like a drug trip
oh this is so Sinister now she's being like loved
oh no are you gonna be okay if we never understand
how they did that we got a whole movie to find
out I know I know some things might be a little
bit better left uh unexplained I thought that
was a really well shot sequence too I wonder if
we like played it back if it would be exactly
90 seconds I'm sure or however runny they said
they went a little over so because sometimes
when they do sequences like that they tend
to be under over there's no way that they act
that up can I hang with you to the house bro
so she's obviously on the fritz with her
dad so she's staying with them and it's
like a surrogate sibling situation and then
thanks Kate I'm gonna have a nightmares Riley
is it her talking or the thing possessing her
probably a little bit of the thing because then
over the 90 seconds I'm looking in the mirror my
reflection is gone like I don't know anything oh
what does the hand feel like it felt amazing it
felt like I was glowing feels like a Supernatural
episode of Black Mirror took too many sleeping
pills accident really intriguing Dynamic oh my God
crastophobia is a constipation okay and
I feel like everybody has that right
hi is Jade home how'd they get their
hands on that hand you better not be
having a party Jade I swear to God
it's two friends can you let him in
what time is everyone getting here getting here
for what the party is there a party tonight don't
[__] me have you got alcohol in your car
oh no I don't drink it's Market you're good
mom what time's the party again more party the
party party tonight what time is it party mom
not drinking tonight on God I will
punch you in the face [Laughter]
the boyfriend wants to do it it's
the hand of a psychic got cut off
in them legit it's a medium just but if you
smash it there's an actual a hand in there
everyone around him thought Mrs cut his hand off
white people [__] man I tell you I'm stoked
we got an explanation film me all right time
with unknown forces things can go
wrong so fast talk to me oh my God
that's cool you don't break her
perspective because we already
saw it we know what's happening I'll let you in
that looks like he's he's dying
he's like transforming
looks like Jesse Eisenberg
he hates it when he died
you make him soft
so it's very evil dead
[Music]
oh you know don't blush
this is really sexually uncomfortable
I would I would stop this guys
I always rubber up against the ground
oh he's me
oh God Greg
stop it
oh that was the last thing I expected
oh that is so humiliating guys
oh yeah those are that was pretty heavy yeah
so insensitive get your
thought dog out and no cameras
I've never seen a device like this in a movie
especially where it becomes like a drug Escape
unbelievably well done I just like
don't know if I like it [Music] it's
really uncomfortable yeah
it's really uncomfortable
but it's unbelievable
this Montage sequence is so necessary
at this point [Music] it's got this
like cynical Macabre madcap Behavior [Music]
[Applause] he does it again [Music]
me too no way what if we did it for like 60
seconds you'd have to be a [__] about all things
Riley wow you're just so busy trying to suck
Daniels don't give a [__] about anybody else
wow why do you want to do it so much to impress
James to come into my room crying that you're
scared like last time I hate you like you're
my favorite person in the world Dynamic strong
Mike actually kind of tense in the
shoulders I know yeah I don't know
that I've ever seen a move that made me like
this icky feeling 50 seconds yeah let's go
you just get the feeling that something
truly terrible is about to happen at any
moment my hair is standing up on
my arms my shoulders actually hurt
you better not cry after 20 seconds that's
how I meant It's very effective talk to me
you say it see someone he knows I'll let you win
[Laughter]
maybe he does choke to death or something
I'm so sorry whoa I never wanna hurt you
I miss you so oh it's her mom so much me
that was the same name this ain't
fun and games he doesn't want him
to go after 50 seconds gonna make
him stay longer it's my mom please
damn
oh let it go please don't leave him in there
oh no no no no no
get it off of him
oh god oh my god get it off of him
no Greg Greg what happened
I think he did
oh my gosh oh [__] oh [__]
okay
what's gonna happen to him
into the ghost of her mom
now please oh and they weren't recording
that one were they did he rip his eye out
I think he like started to I'm not sure
that's kind of happening so fast I wish
you just be honest with me because you've
been so honest with me it means there's
something you haven't told me about
mum have we like never seen his face
it's kind of crazy the idea that she was using
this as like a form of escapism from her pain
and then it just comes full circle to confront her
but why would the ghost haunting thing well there
was claws at the door so she thought that her mom
was trying to get out but maybe the dad locked
her in there or something I don't know maybe she's
possessed she took the hand and she's gonna do it
she's gonna try to reconnect with her mom but she
won't be able to she's gonna perform to record it
tell me he's okay no offense I don't want you here
right now wait Jade come on I wouldn't have um
no no did you give him something no come on
I know you've done [__] before what was
it nothing else where it's not true what did my
son ever do to you oh I didn't hurt him you did
as heavy as hell but that cinematography
is [__] beautiful right now
hmm
[Music]
she like let out
remember her thing about the
mirrors yeah the reflections
it's really her mom or is it just tricks on her
own mind I don't know to be honest it's so hard
to be upset with her because if I had a way to
talk to my mom I probably would have done it too
it's like I want to be so annoyed with her because
she didn't pull him yeah but I love what a movie
does that you kind of debate about it in your
head I love that yeah it's just wildly wildly
well done so effective I just like can't deal
with it I can't go home I know something's out
doing spiral even more I don't want to be alone
okay yikes this is the bad call she's
got like literally no one right now maybe
because she was trying to reach out
she's gonna ask him to do it with her he
could check oh I'm never doing it again man
no the spirit seem like they're trapped in their
like own grief cycle remember when we hold down
and they could feel your heart beating
through your fingertips now this is
getting way too specific it's getting
way too specific it probably still no way
oh guys
why don't they want to tell what happened
because they don't want the hand to get
taken away I mean they probably wouldn't
believe but at the same time if they just
did it edit like cop just did everything
in a court case they would show that's real
suck my ass
as much as there's like this almost
nihilistic approach to the film there's
something about the relationships that
feel so far from what is conventionally
done in a film even right down to this
little interaction here with the mom and
daughter I really hope that her and
that boyfriend don't cross the line
right by the feet that's the sequel
am I looking at a calf right now shin
I don't think I've ever seen a shot like
that what is that a person or no it's her
oh whoa cool I mean this isn't cool
this is a dream I would assume so
in the room is that her dad
whoa
the fingernails
I wonder if she's getting
slowly possessed by her mom
there's not that long left in the movie
it's almost like a slice of Life yeah right
who is this
he's gonna wake up and she's
sucking on his toes or something
it's her doing it right [Music]
the nails on the door remember we don't
remember where they got the hand from
maybe she just did too much possession well
she was over the 90 seconds the first time
is her dad not home I guess not so like
she's going down her mother's descent
she's gonna do it without anybody
this is a terrible idea
she just has to not let them in
I think and she could let it go
yeah always
[Music]
oh don't ruin the moment Riley needs help
that wasn't what I was expecting
what am I looking at oh and her and her mom
oh no this poor kid what's gonna happen right now
oh no
now he's still possessed stop stop him
or is she possessed right now oh
no why would she be possessed
I don't know you're right
oh God
this movie really gets out of your skin it's
not fun no it's not it's not fun it's like
a true like demented deterioration like
what is the lesson in this movie just to
Spook you don't mess with that roof I want to
give you a lesson another be careful what you
wish for kind of what's it trying to say
I woke up and mayor was sucking my feet
so why would you be seeing your mom you didn't
even let her in I didn't like I said I couldn't
even say to people wait who stuck it I
got the hand off him he um the brother
can we talk to him well the brother didn't
die he actually thought he had friends but
you were using him we were using him call
A real friend would have seen him up these
guys are terrible they still kept using
it after that and didn't tell anybody cool
it does feel like a metaphor for like drugs on
the bus yeah get on talk to him his body should
kick him out they get weaker the longer the rain
maybe it's time you stop [__] up people's lives
Joss what do you reckon yeah man you're the
worst worst I didn't say [__] mayor that was
just you and then you let it go for two [__]
minutes and then you sleep with my boyfriend
what the [__] is wrong with you I wish that
you didn't force yourself into my family meal
oh saying we do it again with Riley but throughout
the candle this time you want him to do it again
they're treating the mom like she's like
like guiding her right to make this choice
but is the mom actually a malevolent spirit
I don't know you don't know until we know
what actually happened with the mom we need
the dad to be honest about that and I keep
wondering why they don't show us the Dad's
face mom's [__] like an hour we'll be quick
I absolutely never want to watch
this again I think it's excellent
It's a harsh experience yeah like it's very cold
how do you get him to say it talk to him oh
he's got a requested himself what if I use the
hand to speak to him no what he's not dead me
but what if his spirit is disconnected from his
body or something then disconnect Riley talk to me
is there a boy here
whoa he's like this is like Insidious
oh my God where are we going
[Applause] he's getting eaten alive
and ass visual
not gonna stop you need to send Jade in there
what would be the benefit of sending Jade in
there something with Jade it's all to continue
on JH it has another moment Jade hasn't
gone in something with her she's the key
I haven't been completely honest with you
okay okay let's hear it what was it she left
or something I'd be scared to show you which
is which is wrong of me it's zero idea can I
read it to you it's a letter why would you not
have shared this prior because it means that she
did herself which means the person she's talking
to isn't really her mom it's the first time in a
long time I haven't felt hopeless I am full of
hope I hope you can find some peace and knowing
I have no login page yeah okay [Music]
she didn't do it because she told me that
good
that's the message of the movie you can't change
the circumstances just because you want them to
be different sorry about grief and she's trying to
get to this point of acceptance it's not true no
and the demons that you either accept or
you fight I'll be back promise me promise
do not let her go do you believe
the letter yeah yeah obviously
that's reality why did you write
it I didn't your dad dad what yeah
it's not Max it is her these are the
demons he's going to hurt you [Music]
the hand Riley can't stay there oh
this is so well done this is like
[__] with your heads he needs to die
he needs to die it's the kangaroo moment
hahaha
that's not her dad what is happening that's the
demons yeah yeah but her dad's clearly sitting
somewhere else she's just thrashing
herself around like yeah I think so
[Music] her dad's there
though so he's gonna come help
no she's gonna stab herself no yeah
that's what I'm worried about or she's
gonna hurt her dad when he comes
into oh no do not stab yourself oh
[Music]
bummer this movie is a darker as hell this is
like some real a24 [__] right here just where
do you go from there you just killed your
dad I would probably just want to die right
after that you kill Riley or not it doesn't
even make a difference at this point Kate
are you okay no I know what to do oh no you
know I actually think he's getting better
yeah I woke up for a second she fully let
the demons in oh she's gonna try to kill him
show me what to be here Jade no the demons are
disappearing from our brother on their own he's
weaning them off the more she uses it the worse
she gets it's as a fascinating like drug addiction
until you see it without them yeah I it's just
like relentlessly oppression you got her to leave
so she can go kill her brother yeah [Music] this
part doesn't feel like drug addiction at all it's
just a scissors I mean just like the messed up
choices and stuff you know yeah I hear you man
oh sorry no it's okay oh my God and mom's gonna
forgive her too it's gonna be so mean I know
I was mad you had every right to be no I don't
she's killed her dad the one on drugs Mia I'm so
sorry that I blamed you I know that you wouldn't
do anything to hurt him I love you guys oh no
oh this movie and it means so
much to him that you were here yes
figures it out way
I'm so sorry Greg she's gonna walk in
and see that the dad's dead and then
she's gonna know there's a problem at the hospital
Craig oh no she's seeing his urine
bag filled with blood or something oh
he's doing stuff foundries
oh no thank you he's ours
oh all right some great makeup in this man he's
at the mom walk in I see oh no oh no you saw
Greg it's just like torture
did she kill hers
drop it drop it I want to feel
[Applause] kangaroo kangaroo the mercy kill
all right he's alive Mia Riley
where did she take him where's my son he was in
this room well it should be here he's just here
the classroom
Jade it's your time to shine
honey you haven't had a moment
no
oh why why this method because she's gonna try
to kill herself too or something I don't know
foreign
[Music]
forever
that's your rear Telltale sign
no
what was that I don't know oh
she just she's the deer Greg
tell me what happened what happened
damn she's able to just get up
oh she's on the other side now she's
the demon oh she's looking at it right
[Music]
man visuals are strong yeah
she's become one of them
I'm gonna be so far behind
you got better and everything
no reflection she doesn't exist [Music] Ence
does that mean her dad lives yeah
yeah yeah and it's gonna
be her but who has the hand
[Music]
Wicked
yeah they say talk to me it's gonna
end you just see her and done it's cool
it's going towards the light
yeah oh my God all the way to the other side
I'll let you in Hillary
pesto oh damn where they gonna get to
I'll let you win
that's a great end dude a really good ending
that's a great ass end here I mean it was an
excellent movie they did an excellent excellent
Miranda Otto that's the name of the girl what do I
know her from is it Gray's Anatomy or something I
think we should break it down into categories and
talk it like that I don't know what you mean so
do you tell me what you mean I mean like a week
ago the categories acting oh sure yeah what
do you want to talk about acting this is an
interesting thing that you're doing yeah let's
do it it'll help me create video chapters what
category you want to talk to about you choose no
what it's your thing how about this how about this
let's create categories on the spot and then we'll
choose that would be like me saying I want to have
an immigration plan and then me saying you that
you have to pick which one that is exactly what
it's like but it's your it's your plan man I'm
following your lead now okay directing acting
writing music and like directing following Compass
like cinematography and stuff and and writing and
I think writing director would probably I think we
should write a directing act and uh start like I
don't know if this is actually gonna help but this
might throw us off I am so thrown off I think I've
thrown us off I feel like I thought I was trying
to help us out and I think I just made it worse
start where you want to start all right all right
so you wanted to start with directions I think I
think we should start with our overall emotional
response that's usually what we do too I know I
feel like I thought I was gonna make something
more interesting here and I just derailed
I am very impressed by it and similar to
how I feel about two very separate movies
the way I felt about hereditary and 13. are like
this was such an uncomfortable experience and I
admire so much about it I don't know when I
would want to re-watch it though because it's
it's so mean like it is a mean ass movie and I and
that's part of why I I there's a like I I love it
in a way where I I also like I kind of want to
stay away from it for a while though because
because I love it from the craftsmanship of what
it did and I and I love its commitment to just how
harsh it actually gets instead of shying away from
it and everything around of what it would have
committed to like it is a committed film and it's
so well executed to the point where it is doing
a lot of things that we might have seen in
other horror films like you can feel it's
love and adoration for other horror movies like
you get these sense of things like hereditary uh
Evil Dead and uh Insidious like a lot of and I'm
sure a whole bunch of other ones as well other
possession films but it doesn't feel derivative
at the same time does it feel like they're just
aping it it still feels like they're doing their
own thing which I really appreciated but the
experience itself just kind of left me in a uh oh
that that's a tough one to sit through again yeah
you know yeah and that's sort of where I I land
on it I I will probably one day watch it again but
um the movie's not having any it's not fun
yeah and I thought it might be a little fun
just because of like what I'm familiar with
their work being uh prior and like you know
even even for some like they're not the same kind
of filmmakers at all or same kind of creatives
Prior but even if you look at a movie like get out
they're still fun to be had with get out despite
how like dark it gets and there's something you
know hereditary I wouldn't say for some reason
this this hit me on a harsher level than like
hereditary hereditary was like yeah yeah this
this I think it's because people there's something
that felt so relatable and and uh more communal
because it starts off on a tug and pull of Hope
whereas like hereditary just throws you into
it's just going to be super depressing from
beginning to end this is just like strips you
from I puts you in her perspective it just strips
you from it you know I love when artists set out
to make something and then they make the absolute
best possible version of their Vision yeah which
was this it's like clearly this is exactly what
they wanted to do and they did it at a very
elevated um you know I know people hate the term
elevated horror but like they did it to the 10th
degree the performances the cinematography all of
the categories they did it so well the dialogue
um the design just in general the sound
design too they did everything perfectly
the story they wanted to tell is a story that
I didn't need to hear like if you asked me what
are the best movies of the year I would say this
is one of them if you ask me what are my favorite
movies of the year I would not say this is one
of them yeah there's like an intellectual versus
an emotional right because I feel as if this
is totally this is horror horror this is like
[__] with you to mess with you and like really
it it's not I'm not saying there's no heart in
it because of course there's a family Dynamic but
there was no feel-good element at all and it like
you said it wasn't fun it was so dark and so um
horrible to watch this experience that it was
interesting like I haven't seen a movie that made
me feel like that in a really long time and since
being on this channel and just in the most recent
years I've been getting into horror for the first
time really I mean I grew up watching a lot of the
classics but I I haven't been like a horror junkie
and I don't think I get I'm not easily spooked
even though some things really make me my skin
crawl but more like in a fun way this the whole
time watching it felt like I felt horrible yeah no
I did like my shoulders have been tense this whole
time in a way that truly feels unsettling and
there's like something crawling at my soul in
a weird [__] way yeah and I think that's what
they wanted obviously they want to make you
uncomfortable and I what that's what I liked
about it because so oppressive and the you know
when you see a trailer for something like this
you're going to get the horror you're going to get
the gimmicks you're gonna like that I don't even
really remember the trailer but you'll you'll get
you know the teases of the the visuals and whatnot
and while there's some great visuals here what
what they Excel that is most movies I think will
kind of just rely on that and the jump scares and
spooks this movie knew how to really get to you
on the like the creepiest of psychological levels
and to do that in an efficient run time as well
I don't know I keep bringing up hereditary is like
two and a half hours or something it's a really
long movie this is 90 minutes it's a short tight
film but man does the experience feel felt like
you are this feels longer than that in the way
that I think they wanted it to be because it's not
boring it just puts you into this like haunt you
know the Harry Potter movies the mentors yeah kind
of get that feeling it's like soul sucking you
know a couple things number one because you guys
know I'm obsessed with the actors Miranda Otto
I feel like I can picture her with Mandy pankin
which is making me think that she was in Homeland
that might be where I'm knowing her most from the
redhead the mom which I definitely know her number
two um I don't know what I was what number two was
I was so focused on Miranda Otto maybe if I had
your categories um yeah yeah well the cast uh
what'd you think of the uh the main girl like Mia
they were all great I thought they were all great
I I can't distinguish one from the other being
better or worse they were all effing amazing like
truly every single one of them I thought even like
the the Entourage of people I know that you really
really were harping on me as performance which I
think she did amazing but um she had a lot to do
and she was given the most to do the fact that I
thought some of the other actors that were given
almost nothing to do yeah did made such powerful
impacts like um like Jade um or like the boyfriend
or like the best the two that had the hand um I
just think that they all were so good on nothing
yeah it relies a lot on just natural personality
and natural chemistry yes and I think the the
performers felt they felt like real friends they
felt like the people who really knew each other
it didn't feel like what's this archetype cast
what's his heart type put them there they really
seem like I don't know I I I don't know if the
filmmakers uh knew these people beforehand and
just put them on screen you know together to
play The Ensemble because yeah The Ensemble was
perfectly cast that helped Elevate the experience
of being able to watch them on screen because a
lot of those dudes the guys specifically are so
unlikable the the guy's in charge of the hand
one of them was a dude two or three of them
right the black guy and then the other guy I
just I didn't think that that was like well I
don't know what their pronouns are oh I'm not
sure though I'm unclear I thought it was a guy
I'm not sure you could be totally right okay
um maybe that's me being the and you being the
woke Roxy that you are um it's possible um no no
no you're being respectful I appreciate it maybe
um I'm not sure if I am or I'm not trying to play
Both Sides you're either a woke crazy liberal
or no you're being respectful that's crazy
yeah I don't know oh yeah I really really
don't know the ending was phenomenal the
beginning was phenomenal they really like
they tell you what's gonna happen yeah they
tell you right at the beginning like that's
why I love it at the beginning they keep you
from an observer and then the ending they put you
in her because you're in her perspective yeah you
know as as two people who have grieved
before it is interesting like the way
what we've only grieved just once no no yeah
two people agreed before yeah I've agreed once
two people have creeped several times before um
I think that you do have weird thought processes
sometimes and I think that that this movie did
really go into some of that like what do you
believe what don't you believe your mind certainly
plays tricks on you reality plays tricks on you um
or or like your perception of reality right right
this did a very good job of capturing that with
through a lens that they created oh I remember
what I was going to say earlier was that I really
love that this set its rules and then played by
the rules yeah like we knew that you had to say
talk to me and that is when you could talk to them
and then I let you in is when that happened then
they use that exact rule to get her to go to the
other side with the little girl at the end which
was really smart we knew about like that there
was the candle situation we knew we needed to be
in there under 90 seconds or there was going to be
an issue and we knew that we didn't know exactly
where they were coming from kind of like that
Heath Leisure one how I got these scars we didn't
know whether it was a Satanist or whether it was
a medium or what but that wasn't the point right
it was that there's something in there that has
connection to the outside and that was always what
the case was and that this has been passed around
and passed around they let us know also that the
longer they're in you the more likely you can see
them afterwards and then you might be screwed they
said the the further space there is after they're
gone if you just let them go then eventually
you'll be okay like they really set up all the
things that sometimes I feel like lazy writing
doesn't do where you'll be like wait but why does
this hand work like where'd they get what are you
not going to address that they really laid out for
us without spoon feeding us and it took its time
they laid out for us all the their world and how
this works and then they didn't break their rules
because it was convenient they played by those
rules just really really smart storytelling and
I think the rules you're absolutely right
completely agree and I think the rules
complement the the themes and the psychological
digression of the characters very well like I do
think it's I do think there's a lot of here that's
it's so much about like the theme of Disconnect
seemed very apparent she's always trying to
connect people or on their phones ignoring
her she's ignoring her dad and so much of this was
like if she just dealt with her own [__] which
is easier said than done but if she had if she had
grieved and except accepted she wouldn't have gone
down this route of escapism and I don't know what
the intention on the filmmakers was exactly but
to me it did feel like when people are in a lot of
pain and suffering and they'd be go down the path
of like drug addiction in some way and they they
find a vice to hide from their pain and problems
and how that can contort to manipulate and lead
you down to these terrible choices in life and
then look where it ends up makes makes you end
up landing at and I loved that it was just so
much more deeper Nuance like I I really love the
movie I really appreciated it so much it's just
the ride the ride is tough to be on that's one
of those things I have a question for you though
about as I'm going through all the moments in this
why was there claw marks on the door if her mom
killed herself uh uh maybe because in the final
Heat of the Moment she actually didn't want to
you know that thing was like the split session
they were too late or maybe she didn't like maybe
maybe she actually was telling the truth in some
way no I definitely think she wasn't because of
that letter and what was painted to be but the mom
okay yeah this is the demons do impersonate right
yeah but sometimes the demons are the actual
thing because like she becomes like the actual
ghost at the end so she's not a demon but she's
like a ghost Mia I think she's maybe or she's
a demon yeah he's too far so she would have the
capability of impersonating yeah but she doesn't
or does we are seeing it from one perspective
who knows what she's looking like to them
I think on the directing too they got a brilliant
handle on perspective because this is like yeah
all like for them for the there's rare times
where you cut away from Mia but what Mia's
in the room it's on her perspective yeah every
time I agree with you that they have a really
good grip on it and I would watch any movie
they put out once yeah like there's nothing
they could put out that I would be like I'm not
watching that and I would recommend this movie
to people yeah I just will not sit through
it again and the editing is so sharp yeah
there's parts of it that remind me of like
the the first the Precision of of it of an
Edgar Wright you know I I loved I loved A lot
of it I really did who do you feel like will
like this like is it certain files like horror
Jeff Snyder uh really Dead Merle really yeah
um not just horror junk like you don't think this
is for like specifically for the horror nuts you
think this is just what people love good scripts
I think yeah I think so yeah because I think it's
very character driven and it's really smart
it's it's a really smart movie that while it
uses the brutality of in the violence and does
The Possession horror stuff it it it's more on
the respectable character-driven narratives of
a film like an exorcist in a way where it's I
don't think I saw that that's really long I'm not
as in love with it as everyone else but uh it's
really good it's really good but I'm like yeah
yeah this is really really good really good what
do you think the budget on this was I don't know
It's gotta be small though man but I I mean again
I'm just so like it's so cool to see two two dudes
who came from YouTube yeah they didn't have that
many locations like no no it's on their Hometown
other than Miranda Otto I didn't recognize anybody
and they really like wow they were very smart
about how they spent their time and money in
this I also noticed this like unique production
design Touch where everything was so shadowed and
dark like everything was lit very very dark but
they on the the outfits that people were wearing
they usually had I didn't quite understand the
choice but man does it draw your eye like sheep
Mia was always in this bright yellow there'd be
another scene where it's really dark but Jaden
this bright pink shirt they they managed to make
their characters still pop in these environments
Greg are you trying to justify not having me wear
my black sweater yeah because it was too dark for
this yes we needed the thumbnail colors and the
black just makes it way too dark and I'm still
in Black so I know but your skin how tone helps
bounce it out what are you calling me white oh
are Jews white yeah well not all but I am you'd
be considered white you're tanned right now yeah
well sometimes the sun's out we do live in
Southern California Roxy's like toothpaste
[Music]
um see now this movie made me [__] that's what
happened that's why yeah this movie it's the movie
on that note uh Greg final thoughts other thoughts
um going through the rest of your categories music
solid perfectly dread heavy totally mm-hmm yep
performances the direction the dialogue I know
we referenced a few times the editing really
solid everything across the board it was like
tons across the board honestly yeah really good
I like the uh sexual deviant uncomfortableness of
moments too dogs I think I I love the com again
I just love the commitment to how icky and gross
it is without being without being indulgent for
Indulgence sake you know some movies just try too
hard like let's just go excessive because that's
all we know how to do without any real deeper
context in this movie knew how to find that deeper
context in a way that's why it worked because
the demons could see he's sexually repressed
yeah I think that was I think every choice was
calculated yeah and uh and that's why I'm like no
I wouldn't change a thing about it just it's hard
to sit there yeah yeah totally okay well thanks
for talking to me I'm glad that I talked at you
you talked with me thanks for listening uh no do
you have to pee or we shouting somebody out no
no there's people at the door waiting what yeah
yeah there's other people who are going to film
oh for sure we'll talk to you soon and thank
you for being here don't forget like comment
subscribe five minutes late they're both five
minutes late middle of telling everybody goodbye
Greg that's crazy okay so you're going to find
them too just like it's just worked out because
that's it's about to be the time they're gonna
be here and I just I didn't even know they were
for sure at the door do you want to say bye
to them or no I just love hanging out with
you so much that I was just willing to let them
wait out there for 25 minutes no it's high five
this is like a 1980s I think we can like I think
we can um Freeze Frame It Like an 80s movie over
here wait hold on hold on let me put down my
teeth okay hold on hold on hold on everyone
don't rush me okay where are we looking at the
people yeah okay ready three two one [Music]
really good okay thanks for talking to me
and listening to us and all that good stuff
and we'll see you next time and not feel as
icky sleep well check under your bed [Music]